hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions a car averages 75
miles per hour downhill 60 miles per
hour on flat roads and 50 miles per hour
uphill it takes three hours to go from
town a to town B and it takes three
hours and 30 minutes for the return
journey by the same route what is the
distance between towns a and B a similar
and perhaps easier version of this
problem was asked in a US Math Olympiad
qualifying test I adapted this problem
from the website cubit org pause the
video if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we figure out the distance
between towns a and B let's first write
an equation for the time it takes to go
from A to B the time it takes to go from
A to B will be the sum of three
different times it'll be the time
downhill plus the amount of time on flat
roads plus the amount of time uphill we
can express each of these times as the
ratio of the distance divided by the
speed we can then substitute in the
downhill flat and uphill speeds which
are given in the problem and we'll let
the distances be denoted by unknown
variables we know this time from A to B
is a total of 3 hours so now how do we
write a similar equation going from B to
a well notice that if you're going
uphill from A to B it'll be downhill
going from B to a similarly if you're
going downhill from A to B it'll be
uphill going from B to a the flat roads
will be the same on either one-way
journey so to get the time from B to a
we're going to swap the variables D and
u and this will be a total of 3.5 hours
so we now have two equations but we have
three variables so we can't solve for
each variable explicitly but we don't
need to we only need to solve for the
distance between the towns which is the
sum of DF and you how can we do that
well we're going to do a neat little
trick and sum the two equations so we
add the second equation to the first
let's line up these variables and then
let's add each column the first column
becomes 5d over 150 then 2f over 60 then
5u over 150 and the sum of these is 6.5
we can then simplify each of these
fractions to be 1 over 30 and we now
have one equation we multiply both sides
by 30 and we get rid of these
denominators and we get D plus F Plus u
is equal to 6 point 5 times 30
which is equal to 195 miles and like
magic we have solved for the distance
between town a and town B and the answer
is 195 miles thanks for watching and for
making mind your decisions one of the
best channels on YouTube banks are
watching and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you